hallo herzlich willkommen in SIS Welt
heute gibt's ein richtig leckeres Rezept
denn ich ma Porer und das sind richtig
fluffige türkische
[Musik]
Brötchen für das Rezept bereite ich
jetzt erstmal einen Hefeteig zu dafür
sind die Zutaten eigentlich so aus dem
Vorratsschrank zumindest habe ich Diemer
da und man kann sie dann je nach Lust
und Laune füllen womit man möchte meine
lieber meine Kinder lieben eine
Käsefüllung Morat liebt lieber eine
hakfleischfüllung ich mag auch Käse ich
mag es aber auch mit Gemüse gemischt
also ist immer ganz unterschiedlich und
porschche gibt's in verschiedenen
Variationen in verschiedenen Formen mit
verschiedenen Toppings und ich zeige
euch heute einfach mal so eine Variante
auf die ich heute Lust habe für den
Hefeteig verwende ich ein halben Würfel
Hefe zwei Esslöffel Zucker 200 ml warmes
Wasser 800 g Mehl 200 g Milch zwei
Eiweiß zwei teöffel Salz und g
Sonnenblumenöl zuerst verrührt ihr jetzt
hefe Zucker und Wasser in einer
rührschüssse dann gebe ich jetzt das
Mehl dazu und die restlichen
Zutaten Salz und Öl am Ende und dann
darf der Teig für etwa 10 Minuten
kneten wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr gerne
schon ein bisschen Hitze drauf geben so
30 bis 34° dann erwärmt sich der
Hefeteig und geht später einfach etwas
schneller
auf
jetzt ist der Teig fertig der ist super
nicht so klebrig der ist perfekt
geknetet und jetzt kann ich ihn
rausnehmen zu einer Kugelformen und
abgedeckt für eine Stunde aufgehen
lassen alternativ in der Kenwood einfach
für 40 Minuten oder im Dampfbackofen bei
gerstufe für 30 Minuten
dann würde ich sagen kann ich schon mal
die Füllung
[Musik]
Zubereiten der Teig ist aufgegangen wie
ihr hier sehen könnt richtig schön ich
mache jetzt hier eine Füllung mit
weichem Käse also dieser Weichkäse
berspenisch kennt ihr vielleicht aus dem
türkischen Supermarkt ist kein
scharfskäse sondern aus kilch dann habe
ich hier getrocknete Tomaten in Öl
eingelegt und die habe ich bereits
feingeschnitten und Oliven habe ich
entsteint und auch fein gehackt den Käse
den zerkleidert ihr jetzt einfach so ich
mache später noch eine Portion für die
Kids nur mit
Käse ich weiß nur gerade nicht manchmal
mögen sie Käse und petsilie manchmal
wollen sie halt nur Käse ich mag beides
ich mag
alles hier so
zerkleinern
nehmen da erstmal den Teig hier
raus und dann einfach mal 24
gleichmäßige Portionen einteilen also
erst
[Musik]
halbieren daraus macht jetzt quasi 12
dann hier einfach mal kurz
rundformen jetzt öffnet ihr den Teig so
ein bisschen ihr merkt auch direkt dass
ihr gar nicht wirklich Mehl dafür
braucht weil es einfach ein Teig ist der
nicht klebt ne eisfierer ich neh jetzt
hier mal den kleinen und da kommt die
rein und dann kann das Brötchen
verschlossen werden und ihr könnt die
Brötchen jetzt entweder mit etwas
Abstand auf demem Blech backen damit
wirklich schöne einzelne Runde perfekte
Brötchen werden ihr könnt aber auch auf
einem gesamten Blech backen dass sie
sich so ein bisschen berühren und man
sie auseinander Zehen muss oder ihr
könnt es auch in Muffinförmchen Backen
ich mache später einfach mal beides ich
nehme jetzt einmal ein Blech und später
mache ich noch eine Portion und die
backe ich dann einzeln in Muffinförmchen
dann gebe ich jetzt hier zu den zwei
Eigelben die ich noch übrig habe etwas
Sonnenblumenöl dazu verrühre das ganze
und Streich Brötchen damit
ein und so kommen die Porcher jetzt in
den Backofen der ist noch kalt ich
schalte ihn dann auf 200° oberunterhitze
und wenn ihr habt dürft ihr gerne die
dampfstufe aktivieren dann werden sie
richtig
[Musik]
fluffig während das eine Blech jetzt im
Ofen ist bereite ich hier schon mal die
für die Muffinform vor und da habe ich
jetzt hier die XXL Muffinform von uns
Fette die natürlich und mach dann
einfach zwei Bleche voll also 4 hübsche
schöne leckere Muffins und dann ist es
nämlich auch egal ob es sie perfekt
formt oder nicht denn in der Muffinform
backen Sie einfach perfekt und später
probieren wir mal
[Musik]
gemeinsam
das sieht doch mal richtig gut aus ich
finde tatsächlich beide Variationen
richtig schön ich könnte mich nicht
entscheiden deswegen dürft ihr euch dann
einfach entscheiden aber ich habe
jemanden da der hier heute probieren
darf und zwar Dennis
hey ich bin schon gespannt ja ja kennst
du porschche nee ich Ken nicht Porcher
Porcher porcha Porcher Porer Porcher
sind kleine oder
große türkische gefüllte Brötchen und
eigentlich alles was so handlich klein
einzeln gebacken ist ist porche und
Breck ist mehr so was aus jufkaateig
zubereitet wird okay und das ist jetzt
ein Hefeteig hier Hefeteig okay da habe
ich vielleicht schon mal ähnlich
gegessen aber so hab ich ges bestimmt
die gibt's auch so als ja so so Stangen
Stangen so länglich aber porche ist
alles was so fluffy ist siehtor aus ist
schon so ist schon so also da gibt
bestimmt auch verschiedene Theorien aber
porche ist eigentlich alles was so
Brötchen ähnlich ist und schlang geformt
kurz klein groß egal wie jedenfalls habe
ich zwei Variation gemacht einmal auf
dem Blech und einmal aus der Muffinform
du bist einfach super
kreativ danke kann ich nur
zurückgeben ham ja Dennis macht ja auch
bei uns er ist schon lange bei uns im
Team tatsächlich aber vor der Kamera ja
das stimmt ja richtig gelernter Koch
macht auch viele res für unseren Shop
z.B und ich habe jetzt gesagt Dennis wir
ma jetzt öfter was zusammen ja freue
mich super darf ich probieren egal wo ja
egal also vielleicht nicht aus der Mitte
weil die Fotos
ma
riechen riechen sehr sehr gut ich bin
eigentlich schon immer bisschen
aufgeregt wennemand probiert der V F
guck mal saftig das ist guck
mal schon geil schon ne trockene Tomate
Olive ne Käse sehr
lecker schön kräftig auch schön schö
Würze in der weiche fluffige
Teig seht ihr so probiert man richtig
hier
top vielen Dank das Geruch Aussehen
Konsistenz Geschmack mhm einmal alles
bewertet genau super und wie findest die
[Musik]
Brötchen ich find die wirk sehr sehr gut
die sind schön weis und fluffig schöne
Farbe Perf ich bin aber wirklich dann
aufgeregt wenn du mein Essen probierst
kannst du gar nicht sein weiß D mitile
wie
[Gelächter]
schmeckt toll mhm und das ist auch eine
coole Idee
also die sind jetzt geschmacklich gleich
aber ihr seht auch lassen sich super
rauslösen und wenn man jetzt nicht so
geübt ist im brötchenformen legt man sie
einfach da rein und dann backen Sie
trotzdem perfekt ich glaub das ist eine
ganz coole Möglichkeit das hat mal so
schöne einzelne Törtchen schon süß muss
ich sagen ja bekommen die Kids morgen
mit zur Schule
alle ein paar aber ist immer was schönes
kann man mit zur Arbeit nehmen mit ins
Büro mit zur Schule mit den Kinder
Garten am nächsten Tag aufwärmen oder
auch ein paar einfrieren immer wieder
aufbacken ist ein schönes Rezept ich
lege euch auf jeden Fall beide Rezepte
an schaut euch gerne an auf
sellis-blog.de oder in meiner App und
dann freut euch halt auf alles was wir
so
machen macht's gut bis zum nächsten
Mal
por sehr se
gut